G: I'm obsessed with all beauty gurus. I watch all of their stuff all of the time.
C: They're fine. E: And still never learn anything, because that's what I feel like. G: Nothing, I try to but I still feel like I- why am I so scummy?
G: Hey guys, look, I'm here with Carly and Erin!
All three: Yay!
G: I wanted to come and shoot a video of Carly and Erin,
but more specifically I wanted to see who are your friends and do you know what their faces look like? C: Probably not. G: Basically
there's a challenge that's been on YouTube forever, like, who's that youtuber that where you zoom in on one part of someone's face
and you've to try and guess based on this completely
pixelated thing who that is. So I specifically picked you guys's close friends.
C: Oh oh. G:  That you often collaborate with to see if that adds any ease to this game. C: How far zoomed in is it?
Like are we gonna see cells dividing? G: So my phone now looks like I'm a psychopath.
G: All these photos are different and then like very zoomed-
in different areas. This is kind of a game,
but really it doesn't f*cking matter so you guys can try to shout out your answers until we get to the right one.
C: Okay, fun! G: Okay. Here we go. This is the first one. C: I'm like Liza. G: This where I have to remember who this is. C: Yeah.
E: There's a dark eye.
C: Maybe it's Gabbie?
E: So, either Liza, Gabbie or Zane. C: I feel like it's a girl. Oh my god, you know people's eye colors? You're such a good friend.
C: I think it's Liza or Gabbie. E: Okay. C: I feel like it's Gabbie. G: That's your final answer?
C: I don't know. E: I'm like, based on the shape of the eye, it looks like they're from the region- C: Yeah...
E: I'll say it's Liza. G: You say Liza, you say Gabbie. The correct answer is
Heath! E: Oh, I forgot about Heath!
C: This is way harder than I thought it was gonna be. I was for sure that was a girl's eye. G: Well get ready. Here's the next one.
C: What?!
C: Wait, their mouth- It's Scott. E: How do you know- Oh, because of the beard.
C: Yeah. E: But it also could be Zane. Try to look at the teeth, like are those even teeth?
G: This is where it becomes a magic eye, like if I soft focus my eyeballs on it. E: I feel like it's Zane. That's what I'm gonna say. G: Okay.
C: I'm gonna say Scott, but like maybe it's me, like I don't know.
C: I feel like this is hard. This is difficult. G: Okay, Scott, Zane. Correct answer is Scott!
C: What do I win? G: Uh, just
a good friendship. Okay. Here's the next one. E: What the hell? G: I know who it is. E: Corinna?
C: No, whose smile is that? That looks scary.
E: It looks like, uh, the Joker.
C: Yeah! E: Zoomed in, no offence. C: That's a lip, right?
G: Hmmm... I don't know.
C: It's someone's like scar from a- G: I don't know!
C: Is it Alex? I feel like it's Alex Ernst.
E: Does he smile like that? C: I don't think so, actually.
E: This person is very pale, so like I feel- who's pale besides us?
C: I don't know, like I don't pay attention to anyone but us, Erin. E: God, I don't know, but I think it's Alex Ernst. G: Okay, you're going Alex.
E: I don't know. I think Corinna. G: Corinna? The correct answer is
Matt King!
E: We were literally there! This is so weird. G: It's very strange to see the features of your friend's face like so up close.
E: Imagine, people just start like hanging that on their walls as like
decoration. G: There is my favorite youtuber. E: How creepy.
E: We're gonna really need to start taking this seriously.
C: Get it together. E: The game starts now. G: Okay, ready? Here's the next one. C: Corinna. E: Are they like morphed? What's happening? G: No
none of it's morphed. It's literally just zoomed in, zoomed in. E: I feel like maybe you're right. C: I think Corinna.
C: I think it's her, but like also... E: A demon. C: ...It could be anybody.
E: It looks like a- uh-  a sonogram. C: Yeah!
C: Um... I want to say Corinna for me, final answer. G: Okay, Corinna. E: I agree. I think she's like a good skin tone. G: And the correct answer is
it's Kristen!
E: Oh the eyes! I should have known that one.
G: It's okay it's okay. Ready?
Okay, here's the next one.
E: Glasses, is that also Matt? Who has glasses?
C: What are we- E: What is that?
E: But like I feel like Liza's definitely worn those glasses before, like the fake ones.
Like Liza and Gabbie have both worn them. C: Yeah. E: She's kind of tan.
C: I can't tell if- E:  I literally don't know what that is. C: I feel like it's Gabbie. E: I'm gonna say Liza.
G: You're gonna say Liza, you're gonna say Gabbie? Okay, the correct answer is Gabbie.
E: How did you know about was a lip even?
E: Well, I was right about the glasses. C: Bottom lip, upper lip. E: I don't know.
C: That's how a face works Erin. G: Here's the next one.
G: Well, I thought- C: I thought that was me, I don't know why. E: Well their mouth is open so it could be David fake laughing.
C: Oh, it's definitely David fake laughing. E: Also Zayn, opens his mouth a lot in Instagram photos. C: But Zayn smiles he doesn't like-
C: You know what I mean?
C: I feel like this person isn't totally smiling. E: Yeah.
E: Why's their tongue out? C: And David does that in pictures with his tongue out. E: Should we say David?
C: I don't know. This is hard. E: They're pretty pale, David has a fair complexion.
C: I'm gonna go David. E: Yeah. G: David?
Correct answer: David!
G: I thought that this looks like a vagina for a second. When I went to- Oh no! Okay. Here's the next one. E: Ear?
C: Oh come on. E: It's Zane. C: What? E: It's Zane, he's- it's when he's wearing his jean jacket. C: Oh my god.
C: Yeah, let's go for it. E:  I'm saying Zane. G: Okay, and you are exactly correct!
C: Oh my god, Erin. E: I'm like, am I secretly obsessed with Zane?
G: You guys are getting better, as the game progresses. C: And Erin's getting creepier.
E: Okay, that one. I don't like.
That looks like a movie horror poster like- Is it the dog? Is it Link?
C: Oh my god, that pupil is almost like too-
E: It's so weird. I'm so freaked out.
E: I don't like this picture at all.
E: I'm gonna say the dog.
C: It's gonna be really bad when we figure out who the person is.
E: I don't know. C: It does look like very cartoonish. G: Okay. C: I'm gonna say Link.
G: Okay, the correct answer is Liza Koshy!
E: I'm sweating.
C: It looks like a gargoyle.
G: We have two more, here we go, this is the second to last one. E: Oh, Todd.
C: it's definitely a lip.
E: Otherwise you should go see a medical person.
C: It's not Jason, because they're not injected. E: Yeah.
C: Yeah, I know. I think you're right. I think it's Todd. G: Todd, final answer.
C: I'm like who else could it even- E: Teah, we'll do Todd. G: And the answer is Jason Nash!
E: His top lip looks so skinny. He has lip injections.
E: Get them redone Jason. Touch them up, honey. G: Okay. Here's the last one, ready?
C: What? What is that?
C: That's nothing. E: It looks like a little giraffe.
C: It does. G: Oh yeah. Okay.
C: This literally looks like it's He-man.
G: This one is really not- and you can't really figure out what this is. Once you find out what it is
you can kind of see it, but- E: Like is this the eyes?
C: I feel like it's Alex with that scary mask that he broke- E: The grandpa one?
E: It really looks like a ball sack.
E: I'm like it's a ball sack. G: I wanted to see if you guys knew your friends genitals, and- E: Oh my god, I have no idea.
C: I'm gonna go with Todd. E: We'll just do Todd. C: Because we haven't done him yet
G: And it's Todd!
G: It's the eyebrows and the forehead. It looks like a g- C: It's so wrinkly up close.
G: And so shaded-  E: That's terrifying, Todd your face looks like balls.
G: On that note. How do you guys feel after playing the game? C: I feel like a bad friend. E: Other than that, I'm obsessed with Zane.
G: This game- I don't think have to feel like a bad friend because it  means you don't stare longingly at your friend's face. C: Yes,
but maybe you should.
E: We just do that now, people think it's so creepy.
G: Thank you for playing, you guys, I don't- I mean you got a couple correct. E: Yeah. G: Zane like immediately.
E: I'm so sorry that I thought you were a dog, Liza. C: Oh my god,
yes.
My Social Blade: red. G: Make sure you guys go over to Carly and Erin's
channel, because we made a video- are we making video. E: Yeah. G: Okay, we made a video.
And I think it's really fun.
G: See you guys next time. I don't know. E&C: Bye!
G: I don't know what's real or fake anymore about fighting. C: Me neither.
G: Did you just take my soul?
*Laughter* C: End of the video.